we're here it's 2017 it's a real show
it's not a countdown best of 2016 show
this is genuinely and truly the first
real bona fide authentic program of 2017
and there's so much to talk about I
tuned out on politics for a little bit
at the end of our a catered towards
particularly towards the beginning of
our vacation there I'll talk about the
vacation Pat will talk about his wild
and and amazing roadtrip adventure on
the bonus show but there is too much
going on in politics to delve into that
right now first of all President Obama
imposing additional sanctions on Russia
course over the alleged interference
with the United States election as per
the FBI and CIA is agreement Russian
President Vladimir Putin responded by
refraining from any reciprocal
retaliatory action now the right-wingers
have gone bonkers saying wow look at
Putin's restraint look at how skilled
Putin is here uh tactically with
politics now yes we know that Vladimir
Putin is very very skilled politically
but you have to remember you need a
reason to take action against diplomats
that are in your country and it's sort
of a red herring to say look at Putin
not doing anything if Putin word to say
well just because the United States is
impacting our diplomats over alleged
hacking we are going to do something
capricious an arbitrary to retaliate
that would be seen incredibly negatively
so I think by damir Putin understanding
that he has no real reason to take
reciprocal of retaliatory action so back
to the main storyline President Obama
outgoing President Donald Trump incoming
how does Donald Trump react to the
action by President Obama against Russia
by praising Vladimir Putin as very smart
as he did on Twitter Donald Trump saying
great move on delay by Vladimir Putin I
always knew he was very smart and of
course retweeted and liked and favorited
tens of thousands of times Trump also
posting
the tweet as a graphic on Instagram up
Trump went out of his way Pat to ensure
that as many people as possible saw that
he finds Vladimir Putin to be a really
smart guy yeah really makes you question
where Donald Trump's the allegiance is
to I mean I understand Donald Trump and
brocco bomber are from different parties
but you think you would take the current
president the united states over a
foreign dictator like but Amir Putin I
think that when you break it down to its
component parts you come to that very
quickly the reaction from some has been
hey we don't actually have proof that
Russia hacked ok but then Trump saying
Putin's really smart after the current
president sanctions him is very very
disconnected from whether or not you
believe the FBI and CIA about Russian
hacking others are saying you know
Vladimir Putin's not really that bad and
I think Pat bottom line dit forest
pretty clearly if we distill the main
point the president-elect is siding with
the recently sanctioned foreign dictator
over the President of the United States
but not just any foreign dictator rather
one accused of interfering in our
election and one that was called by the
last Republican nominee Mitt Romney our
greatest geopolitical foe a sentiment
that at the time Republicans basically
agreed with and now all of a sudden this
entire Russia is thing is no big deal
now shortly after this pack up questions
about whether this was a treasonous act
by president elect Trump started
circulating on social media I guess
loosely defining treason is betraying
one's country I think treason is
actually going too far here particularly
when we know there's going to be much
much worse during the next four years of
Trump I don't want to get into a the boy
who cried wolf scenario I don't believe
that this was treason I think that this
is a serious confusion about what are
the priorities of the United States what
is in the best interest of the United
States in foreign countries allegedly
interfering in our elections is not in
our best interests yeah I don't think of
it as treason but it certainly is odd
that he just continues to praise lad
Amir Putin time and time again oh yeah
you have to wonder if he has some sort
of leverage over Trump and has some
information about him that he's keeping
private for now it's super interesting
to watch this
bella and then the more that we see the
buddy-buddy stuff with the Trump
transition administration from
transition team and Russia the more I'm
wondering what is the truth behind the
scenes tax returns are a big part of
this that that could shed light on to
what's going on I'm going to talk about
that a little bit uh when all of this
was happening I was in London for for
the end of the year break real confusion
over there I mean here were
rationalizing what happened in one way
over there it's just like what on earth
is wrong with people in the United
States how how did this guy get elected
right don't you put your own country
before other countries I thought that
was this whole thing America first yep
flabbergasted people just don't end they
had people i met would expect me to
explain it to them and i sort of give
them an analysis where you already have
to understand how nuts things are here
otherwise even my analysis is not going
to make sense to be the average european
person thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the david
pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated